je vous le disais en titre c'est
l'événement commercial de l'année avec
ces 300 000 visiteurs attendus la foire
de tour a débuté ce vendredi au Parc des
Expositions plus de 450 exposants sont
présents sur place jusqu'au 14 mai et 10
jours d'animation en tout genre avec
cette année la Corée comme invité
d'honneur Clémence d'os que s'est rendu
sur le village gastronomique à la
rencontre de ses adeptes regardez
[Musique]
ça sent les rayons ça sent les frites il
y a aussi de la paella de l'andouillette
bref déplaves d'ici ou d'ailleurs on est
à la foire de Tours et plus précisément
au village gastronomique c'est un petit
peu l'événement le point de rendez-vous
de tous les tours en jeu et les tours en
gel en général on vient entre amis en
famille et le vendredi à 12h30 on y voit
surtout des gens qui viennent entre
collègues c'est qu'une semaine dans
l'année donc si on en profite pas
maintenant nous on fait toujours
andouillette de 3 et une glace ou une
gaufre chantilly tous les ans à
l'ouverture c'est une tradition
ah oui c'est une tradition entre nous de
venir rendre visite justement à des amis
à de la famille tout le monde se
retrouve sans un moment convivial cool
donc voilà le coin des gourmand c'est
avant tout un village de producteurs
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des personnes des
artisans qui viennent mettre en avant
leur savoir-faire et l'authenticité de
leurs produits c'est le cas notamment de
la brasserie l'aurore qui produit la
Turenne ils sont là depuis 14 ans c'est
vraiment important qu'on soit là pour
montrer nos produits notre savoir-faire
artisanal on est vraiment très contents
on a nos habitués bah qui viennent qui
viennent tous les ans qui attendent la
foire pour venir nous retrouver et pour
venir en fait retrouver le village
gastronomique parce qu'on est le dernier
village gastronomique de cette ampleur
de France ici il y a des habitués mais
aussi des petits nouveaux la foire de
Tours est une belle vitrine pour eux
mais pour cela il faut se démarquer en
mettre plein la vue pour attirer les
visiteurs c'est le premier jour ça
démarre très bien les gens nous
accueillent très bien on a essayé de
faire un stand tout en couleur pour se
démarquer un petit peu des autres ça
représente beaucoup pour nous parce que
c'est on sort de notre confort habituel
où on a l'habitude d'accueillir les gens
chez nous dans notre univers là on vient
s'adapter à un univers qui a déjà bien
implanté
[Musique]
du sucré du salé à boire à manger il y a
une centaine de stands au village pas de
panique si vous voulez tout goûter la
foire de Tours et là jusqu'au 14 mai
[Musique]